seafood is a staple of diets in this
country and around the world forgetting
it is problematic overfishing is a
serious issue in our oceans and fish
farms bring a host of health and
environmental hazards but now some
innovative food companies are finding
success with a creative substitute for
seafood fish fillets and other products
made entirely from plants and diners are
getting hooked when we serve these
upstairs a lot of people don't know the
difference they don't it doesn't look
any different chef Brad farmerie Smith's
tree meal is called ahi me a vegan
tomato product that looks and tastes
like raw tuna a must order at his New
York City eatery Saxon and parole chef
farmerie says the taste is so OnPoint
even meat eaters order it what
percentage of your customers order your
vegan options you know it's probably
over the national average we probably
get about 15% really but quite often
when they see something where they can
have tuna or the ahi me each guests will
get one of each and so that way they can
taste they can try they can compare what
did i do by just eating that as opposed
to some real tuna tartare so tuna are
actually really over fished and there
are a few left in the oceans so our
mission is really about protecting
endangered species while bringing
incredible flavors to the consumer David
Benz again is CEO and co-founder of
ocean hugger foods the company behind a
he me
he says his plant-based alternative to
tuna is cheaper healthier and
environmentally friendly and very much
in demand what consumers are really
drawn to this product we have obviously
vegetarians are very interested in it
but it's much bigger than that we have
folks who are just looking to reduce how
much animal protein they're eating for
health reasons those who are concerned
about mercury folks who are allergic to
seafood and we're seeing just a lot of
Millennials who aren't even thinking
about why they just think this is a
really cool thing they like to make a
difference and they're excited they can
do it in such an easy way the United
Nations estimates 85% of the
old commercial fish populations are
fished to the max over fished or in
decline if you can give consumers
everything that they like about fish but
do it with plants it's going to be ten
times as efficient and significantly
less polluting 100 percent of people in
the developed world factor taste price
and convenience into their decisions
about what it is that they're going to
eat bruce friedrich heads up the good
food Institute a nonprofit promoting
alternatives to traditional meat and
dairy products
although retail sales of plant-based
seafood in the US last year only totaled
nine point three million dollars
friedrich predicts sales of seafood
alternatives will skyrocket like
dairy-free milk which 37% of American
households purchased in 2018 as
plant-based seafood companies come
online with more and more products and
consumers try them and consumers like
them we're gonna see this market become
a multi-billion dollar market in the
next decade chef Chad Sarna was hoping
to reel in some of those profits with
his startup good catch
look at this it looks like tuna so it
does look like tuna it doesn't that was
the whole goal with with Purdue creating
this product so it's bits of fish free
tuna this fishless tuna is made of
legumes and seaweed you gotta make a
cookbook you know how I suggest you do
it by you eating in all the photos it
can be used in dishes from pasta and
there you go a fishless linguini two
rice bowls and sushi rolls could I make
this at home of course you can make that
at home everywhere you turn there's
there's more statistics about what's
going on with our oceans and the
contaminants that are in fish these days
especially the plastics that are found
in fish and so being able to create
something that people are used to when
it comes to texturally nutritionally
flavor-wise and functionality it was
really important for me for from a
culinary standpoint so you are seeing a
demand huge demand everything from fast
casual restaurants to institutions and
universities the demand for plant-based
is grown exponentially the past 10 years
good catch cells three varieties of its
fishless tuna just under $6 a packet
at Whole Foods later this year customers
will also be able to buy crap free cakes
and fish free sliders and burgers I'm a
taco girl that's awesome
as for ocean hugger the company hopes
its raw tuna substitute will win more
people over at the sushi counter later
this year an eggplant eel and carrots
salmon will hit the market we hope that
we can help to tilt the scale so that
we're not depleting the ocean so quickly
and putting us all in peril but we'd see
the opportunity just rising as costs go
up and as resources go down for for
seafood products you know everybody
asked me does it taste like fish right
so I say well it doesn't taste exactly
like fish but the texture is great
and it's good it's good but you have a
clean palate I was a vegan for many
years
hopefully you meat eaters you know give
it a try you come around yeah it's a
good point though also even if it's not
about the health that you're not looking
for that think about what is in the fish
think about the fish population it is
something certainly to consider all
those other factors
she's a taco girl